Hello everybody!
It's a little awkward that like, you know, the very first gaming stream that I do is Neopets and not Inkpens.
Look, I don't know if you guys know, but like Neopets has been something I wanted to stream for like so very, very, very, very long.
And I was like, oh my god, I can finally do it!
I can finally stream Neopets!
Also, apparently, apparently this game... the servers are now very bad.
So most likely, because I'm streaming Neopets, I am going to clog up the server even more.
So that's a little...
not reassuring for me.
So I hope that I'm actually able to like explore this game.
By the way, I have not played Neopets in a very, very, very, very, very long time.
The last time I've touched Neopets was when they first introduced the Neopets cash mall.
And then they like converted all the Neopets into like these dress-up dolls.
So like, that's around the time...
I sort of quit.
Because like, I thought...
I was like, these are...
they're ugly.
I was just like...
I was like, oh man, they're pretty ugly now.
So like, I lost my enjoyment of Neopets.
But also because another thing that happened...
Also Gabriel, thank you for the Akasufa!
Thank you, thank you!
Happy Lunar New Year!
Cheers from HK Dragoons!
Thank you!
So another reason was that...
um...
I lost my main account.
And I was like a billionaire on my main account.
And I basically...
What happened was that...
my main account got hacked.
But they not only daily hacked my main Neopets account.
But they also...
What they did was they hacked my email account associated with my main account.
And then they used the email account to hack other accounts.
Because I got the email back.
And I saw other...
I saw other accounts associated on my email.
And then I...
The thing was...
Because I saw other email...
Other accounts on my account...
I was so sad that my main account got hacked.
That I...
That I logged into the other stolen accounts to try and steal their stuff.
So I kept cutting some things back.
And then I was like...
No you don't understand!
I lost...
In my safety deposit box...
I had like...
Like paint brushes.
And like advent calendars.
From like...
So long ago.
You don't understand.
So anyway...
I lost like everything.
But my one unconverted pet.
Which was a...
I don't know how to pronounce it.
You know like those...
Dark purple...
Wolf ones.
The Darragons.
Like a Darragon...
Darragon Lupe.
And it was an unconverted pet.
And that was all that remains for me.
For my account value.
So anyway...
After all of that happened.
I like quit Neopets.
Because I...
I was like...
I lost everything.
I...
Why should I keep playing?
I don't have money anymore.
I don't have money.
I don't have...
I have nothing in my...
My safety deposit box.
All my rare items are gone now.
By the way...
I also had like 3 other side accounts.
That was used as the Labre.
For those who don't know what the Labre is...
It's big...
Okay, I'm pretty sure I'm saying a lot of random words.
And a lot of people don't know what I'm talking about.
Because it's like a lot of fucking random words.
And it's like jumbled up together.
And they're like, what the fuck is she saying?
Hahaha...
Oh my god.
But anyway, there is like a lot of stuff.
A lot of stuff going on.
Also, a little bit of a note.
For those who are wondering.
All I will say is that...
All I will say is that I will put up another statement later on.
Because I believe there are some lies being told right now.
And I have further evidence and proof later on.
So that is all I'm going to say regarding this.
Uh...
Regarding this, if there is anything going on, there will be a future statement being published by me.
Later on.
And that will further support my evidence.
And if you guys hear anything, there is a lot of slander and a lot of lies going on right now.
And that I will be publishing a future statement in the future regarding it.
Which I have evidence and receipts.
As well as backed up by my lawyer.
So that is all I will be saying regarding anything that is going on at the current time.
Um...
Anyway...
Anyway, all I really want to do...
Uh...
All I want to do is that...
I want to just play Neopets.
And...
And regarding a...
Document...
There was a signed legal...
There was a signed...
Doc...
There was a signed legal consent between me and the management.
That it was just going to be between me, my lawyer, and management.
But the fact that they released that to others is considered illegal.
Because that was not supposed to be seen by anyone else.
And it was signed by me.
My lawyer.
And other lawyers.
Um...
So that is all I'm going to say.
Uh...
Regarding everything.
Um...
Anyway...
I can say this because...
My medical history and my medical documents and everything...
That me, my lawyer, and other...
Other people that were involved with...
It was all signed and agreed upon.
So...
Regarding this...
Um...
It was very unfortunate...
That...
That was done.
Anyway...
I do have more evidence and more receipts and more statements later on.
Anyway, all I really want to do is play Neopets.
And nothing about that is going to stop me from playing Neopets.
Because Neopets brought me a lot of joy.
Um...
Because that document...
Also has...
Private information regarding me.
And regarding...
Uh...
Things that should never have been public to anybody else.
But me and my lawyer.
So...
That is all I'll say.
Um...
Anyway...
Uh... Sorry, I had to make that statement.
Because I believe that...
Uh...
There was another thing that was going on at the same time.
And...
And that...
Uh...
Um...
I had to make that statement.
As someone else has been messaging me about these things.
And...
I really wanted to say that out right now.
But I will be making a further statement regarding this.
That my lawyer has written out for me.
And has been planning...
And we were planning on releasing it later.
But because of what's going on right now.
We will release it sooner than later now.
Uh...
Yes, I really wished...
I was going to...
I really wanted to move on from all of this.
But...
And was going to move on.
And everything.
Um...
And was never going to address this anymore.
But because...
They've decided to address it.
Even though I wanted everything...
To be over with.
Um...
That is not my fault.
And...
Because of this, I will have to...
I will have to...
Um...
Respond...
With...
Um...
With a document that my lawyer and I have written up.
Just in case something like this did happen.
And because of that...
Um...
I guess I will be releasing this document very soon.
I prepared something just in case.
But I was going to keep it quiet.
And keep it private.
And because that has happened...
Um...
That has happened.
That means that I am now...
Required to release my story.
And release my statement.
Um...
And I'm very, very saddened.
That my privacy was violated with this.
As...
This document that they're saying...
Was never supposed to be out between...
Other than between me and my lawyer.
And...
Um...
And the other lawyers.
So...
Um...
We signed it and said that it was supposed to be kept between us.
And the fact that they did not keep that promise.
And the fact that they released it to public.
And the fact that like...
People that shouldn't have been reading this...
Read it.
And has my private information regarding it.
Um...
That was very unfortunate.
So I try to leave on very...
As good as I can.
Um...
So yeah.
I'm very...
It's very unfortunate that this happened.
While...
I...
I wanted to have a good...
First week.
And...
Um...
And like I said, this is the only thing I will say.
And...
Um...
My lawyer and I will release...
The document that we prepared.
That we were preparing.
In case something like this...
Did happen.
Yep.
So...
Alright, that's all I'll say.
Uh...
Um...
Anyway...
Uh...
Let us...
Create our Neopad.
As we all know.
I wanted to create a...
Um...
Pateri.
I really wanted to create a Pateri.
Also, I'll also say that I've heard slander about me behind the scenes.
And outright lies being told about me.
But what they do not know is that I have receipts that this proves a lot of things that were said about me behind the scenes.
And it's very unfortunate that I had to make that public.
That we'll have to make it public later on.
Yes, anyway.
So yes, I really, really wanted to...
I really, really, really wanted to do...
Do a Pateri.
And because it is...
I felt like that fits...
That really fits the Dragoons.
And I think like because of all of this happening...
I believe I will have to talk to my lawyer after the stream.
So we're going to keep this stream very short.
But everything else will be on schedule.
Everything else will be on schedule from here.
And...
And for tomorrow, I'm still going to do the Apex Legends.
Season launch.
And everything else will be kept on schedule.
But unfortunately...
Unfortunately, because of everything that's going on...
I will have to talk to my lawyer.
And...
I will have to talk to my lawyer about all of this.
And finish up the document that we have been working on.
So that's very unfortunate.
I really wanted to have a good first stream starting this week.
But because of timing...
I really want to keep everything private.
And really wanted to move on from here.
But it was very unfortunate that all of this happened.
So...
I will try my best to make up for you guys.
And we will try to have another Neopets stream in the future.
But for now...
Let us just make the Dragoon, I guess.
I really do thank all of you guys.
I really do thank all of you guys for...
For being here.
And for believing in me.
And everything.
A lot of...
I really do appreciate it.
Everybody.
Despite everything that has happened.
I was very sad to find out...
A personal document that was only shown between three different parties.
Had to be leaked.
And leaked out.
Umm...
Because it was...
A document I made...
For my lawyer.
And it was a document...
That was not supposed to be shown...
Anywhere else.
But to me...
And my lawyer...
And to the lawyers...
On the other side.
And we were promised...
It was not to be shown...
Anywhere else.
So the fact...
That...
Umm...
And this was...
A document that was made...
That was supposed to...
Help me figure out...
What was going on...
Between me and my lawyer.
And to see if...
Things that were happening...
Was actually happening.
And then we showed it to...
The other...
The lawyers...
Just to see...
To see if like...
They can...
Figure out if what was going on...
Was actually happening.
And we were promised...
It was never going to show...
Be shown...
Anywhere else.
So the fact...
And the fact...
That this has happened...
Really...
Messes me up.
Because I have said...
That I felt...
A very lack of trust...
For a while.
And...
Umm...
I...
I'm just left speechless...
That...
My trust has been...
Broken again.
Regarding...
What I've thought...
Was kept private.
Umm...
So...
Yeah...
Umm...
That's really...
It...
And...
Further...
Statement...
Regarding...
All of this...
I will...
Talk to my lawyer...
And...
We will be releasing...
Another statement...
About this...
Later on.
Alright...
Umm...
Uhh...
Anyway...
Umm...
Sorry...
Haha...
I'm sorry...
I'm just happy that...
Umm...
I just got a friend that messaged me...
That I was just saying...
That they're there for me...
With all of this happening...
So...
It was really reassuring...
To know...
That...
My friends...
Are still there for me...
After all of this...
And...
Uhh...
I'm just really happy that...
Like...
They're still there...
And they're seeing me...
And they're seeing what's happening...
And they know...
What's going on...
And...
They're still there through...
Uhh...
There to support me...
Oh...
Anyway...
Umm...
I'm just gonna name...
Haha...
We're just gonna...
It's really sad...
Cause I was really looking forward to Neopets...
I was really...
Haha...
Looking forward to Neopets...
I was ready to move on...
With everything...
Um...
But yes...
Uhh...
Umm...
My lawyer is ready to talk to me now!
Sooo...
Hahaha...
Haha...
My lawyer is ready to talk to me soon...
So I'm gonna have to call it here.
Guys...
I'm really sorry...
I'm really...
Sorry...
With everything...
So...
Umm...
I'm sorry that I had to cut this short...
I...
I was really looking forward to moving on and rebuilding myself.
So, it is...
It's very unfortunate.
It really says a lot though.
That people would try to bring down others when people are ready to move on.
It really says a lot.
So I'm just gonna call it here.
Thank you everybody.
I'm sorry that we couldn't really have...
We couldn't really...
We couldn't really have this Neopets stream.
I was really looking forward to it.
And I guess I'll...
See you guys later everybody.
Bye guys.